all right good morning every everyone
welcome to jail
car Let's see we
got we have one two three four four all
right represent hacking Phillips you can
sit in for representative Schmidt
because I don't think he's going to be
here great thank
you
and two three Senator gray for for
Senator
Enis we have
Ward and chandley good morning
and grassy you can sit in for repres for
Senator
Whitley
okay the minutes of the previous
meeting move to adopt set all right
seconded by uh representative ly let see
was first any discussion comments or
corrections to those
minutes
seeing none those in favor I all in
favor all oppose sorry we've already had
the favor excuse me and no none
opposed thank you very
much okay and
the consent
agenda is there anything to be removed
from the consent
agenda Madam chair I move the consent
agenda as it presented
second seconded by Senator gray is there
any uh discussion on the consent agenda
those in favor I I
opposed all right very
good moving right along and the board of
Podiatry uh so there are two proposals
from the board of P Podiatry today the
first is 2022
233 the only comment that we had on this
particular uh rule is that the rules are
expired um number of them have been
expir or actually excuse me all of them
have been expired since April of
2019 and they include sections such as
application and supporting documents
timeliness of
credentials um type of examination and
also fees um so there is a question of
whether the board hasn't been enforcing
any of these sections in violation of R
541 a22 while they've been expired um
specifically if they were collecting
fees during this
time and additionally the new PLC rules
that were adopted back in July 2023 do
have the fees for this board so it would
really be a question of whether or not
fees were collected between April of
2019 and July of
2023 there's also um two notes to the
committee one about uh the feed On The
Board website uh once again when we were
looking at the fee compared to the PLC
rule there was a bit of a discrepancy
however upon further investigation it's
due to that mandatory professional
health program fee of
$28 uh the other informational note is
um once again on the PLC fee rules um
and finally on page two there is a edit
unclear comment it was made unclear just
because it was new and was not
um on the final proposal because this
was a conditional approval and um there
was some additional language that was
inserted in there that uh just made it
unclear as written so just wanted to
bring that to the committee's
attention
Okay good morning Tina Kelly with the
office of professional life insurance
certification um with regards to both
the 300s and the 500s I went back and
looked at the board's previous
disciplinary actions and there has been
no disciplinary action taken for any of
the expired
rules um as far as the fees go I'm going
to have to look into that I do not know
if oplc collected fees during that time
so I can let you know whether or not
they did
that um I think we addressed the
difference in the fees and that was due
to the fact that um oplc on the website
combines the um fee for the application
fee and the um professional health
program fee all into one so that people
aren't submitting and and getting
confused and I'm not sure where where
was the unclear comment that I need to
address um it's in the it's the very
last section um of the 300s or the the
this is the 300's proposal um so it's
P22 23
33 we we will delete that that is um we
should have deleted that so that can
come out I have no problem with
that are there any other issues I
addressed I believe that was it for this
proposal representa thank you so in
light of House Bill 409 where oplc now
is is responsible for licensing and Nic
ing renewals does do these rules reflect
that because in some cases I think they
refer to the board where they should be
referring to
oplc so we've tried to address that but
these were back before that all so I'm
trying to catch those things as they go
forward
um so I can't guarantee you that I
haven't caught every single instance but
we are trying to catch them all and if
we don't when they come back again we'll
we'll finish cleaning them off think 10
years is a long time to
wait and just for the record uh this
particular proposal was filed back in
2022 and that's why it's the bill was
not in effect at the
time so how does this and so how does
how do we address that the fact that we
have legislation now that conflicts that
conflicts with rules and we don't really
we don't want that and um there's also
the um discipline AR components of fines
which are also part of oplc now so I'm
trying to how do we is this something
can we is there something that we can
fix between now and next month so that
we can give a conditional approval
knowing that with the understanding that
these things will be
addressed um so this could certainly be
postponed to give the board an
opportunity to look and see if there's
anything that needs to be changed and
then they could submit a revised amended
conditional approval to address that if
the board is willing to do
that we need to do that we
can't I mean we change the law and we
can't adopt a rule that's going to be
valid for 10
years that's based on the previous law
so I hate to make you do it but it needs
to be gone over and updated and also we
would want a report on what happened
with the fees for the two plus years
this was not enforced
I I I'll accept your uh your word that
there were no disciplinary actions but
the I'm I'm more concerned about the
licensing fees and Madam chair if we're
going to postpone this this will need a
waiver second those in favor of asking
for a waiver I opposed all right thank
you we we will request a waiver and
request some a lot of cleanup work on
part of oplc so mam J the motion was to
postpone till next month and allow the
agency time wave any any time
constraints and allow the agency to
adjust correct right thank
you uh so this next one is also the
board of P Podiatry it's 2023 118 sorry
I only did
one um this uh particular proposal only
includes one uh section and that has to
do on the code of ethics um so the only
comment I had on this was that this rule
has also been expired and this one was
expired since December 15
2022 Miss Kelly already reported that
there were no disciplinary actions in
the period of
expiration but uh wonder how we managed
to let this sort of important rule
expire without anybody worrying about it
so to explain that back back um a few
months ago we had reported to the
committee that we were working on
cleaning up all of the um expired rules
so now last month this month maybe even
next month you're going to see them
getting to the point where they're
coming through and getting to that final
okay part of
the thank you Senator Lang move to
approve any
discussion
those in favor I
opposed all right so postpone here and
that
12 all right Landscape
Architects uh so this is
20123 12 um Landscape Architects
on excuse me uh Landscape Architects
this particular proposal um has an
amended conditional approval that was
filed um however was filed after the
deadline so the committee is going to
have to vote on whether or not to accept
the amended conditional approval first
um and if it is accepted um there was
let's take care of that so does someone
have a motion to
accept
discussion Jim second the grade seconded
yes I understand that I asked if there
was any
discussion not seeing any those in favor
I opposed
all right now please continue yep and
the amended conditional approval took
care of all the substantive comments so
the only um two remaining comments on
this proposal are two notes to jail car
one about the PLC rules and the other
about um the board statute um that
authorizes the board to set fees is
still technically in effect but as we're
working on
that I I'll take responsibility for for
getting that one fixed
and and that was all the comments I had
okay then any discussion
questions
approve
conditionally yes accept the conditional
approval reest second second by
representative Lynn discussion those in
favor I
opposed all right thank you very
much uh the the watercraft safety rules
oh we need to move postpone those yes
the agency has requested that this be
postponed so that they can work on a
conditional approval um no waiver is
needed
seconded okay any discussion those in
favor I I
opposed postpone that one uh
HHS um so this is the rules on the radio
nuclides in The Healing Arts um once
again there was an amended conditional
approval filed but it was filed after
the conditional approval deadline so the
committee will have to vote on whether
or not to accept the amended conditional
approval how long after the
deadline good morning uh Nicole Valena
Department of Health and Human Services
um I received
the I received like the FP packet back
like one day before the conditional
approval I filed immediately got that
back filed same day or next day okay
fine V to
accept approval
seconded by representative repres Leon
all right um and those in favor I I
opposed
okay please and with the amended
conditional approval uh attorney Reeves
did not have any remaining substantive
comments uh on this particular
proposal um the only is the agency may
need to pursue a legislative carveout
exemption for this program from the
requirements of our safe
541a
um um could you explain that for someone
um I apologize I'm reading her notes um
as attorney Reeves is not here this
morning unfortunately she's not feeling
well um I I can speak to her if you
would like if you would mind thank you
um so actually first off uh attorney
reev did submit some additional comments
that I actually spoke with the
administrator of the program about we
think we can actually make all of them
however uh to attorney reichard's Point
regarding attorney Reeves notes um this
program is the radiological health
section for Department of Health and
Human Services and they are kind of
their hands are tied for lack of a
better phrase with regard to certain
passages the way the rule is written
because it has to be adopted completely
as is with respect to abiding by and
being um in compliance with the nuclear
regulatory
committee or commission's uh rulings so
certain passages have to be adopted
completely as is um so that is sort of I
think what they're speaking about with
regard to potentially having a carve out
legislatively where this might be exempt
or something because it has to be
adopted to be in
regul all right so we've got another
program wrapped up in federal red tape
that we can't
properly
control uh would you I think what we
should do is ask the program
to get some legislation going on that so
we can debate whether it should be done
that way or not okay thank
you okay nothing further nothing else
okay move to approve and is so long as
the department will seek legislative uh
assistance from one of the the the board
members yes we'll we'll discuss it and
see what um is most appropriate with
respect to this thank you okay is there
a second second second by representative
Lyn
discussion those in favor I
opposed all
right and Board of
Nursing also needs to be postponed yes
the board has asked that this be
postponed to November and the committee
does not need waiver for this one move
to
postpone
second any
discussion those in post
post okay well postponed all right
physical
therapist all right so this is another
one where there was an amended
conditional approval filed um after the
conditional approval deadline and I just
want to make clear that the conditional
approve approval was filed before the
deadline but this is the amended
conditional approval and we are now
asking the committee vote to accept
those if they're filed after the
conditional approval deadline move to
accept second any discussion those in
favor
sosed all right thank thank you for
getting it in
you uh so this proposal has to do with
continued status it's a very long
proposal as it includes pretty much the
entire 400 chapters
a number of the sections are expired um
there was 11 sections in total um that
have been expired that deal with things
such as license subject to reinstatement
maintenance of continuance and
competency uh direct supervision of
physical therapists or physical
therapist assistant student um so all of
those have been expired some since 20
December 2021 and others since October
there's also that informational note
about the PLC rules um on pages
315 16 of the amended conditional
approval with the final note found after
the
appendix the next comment is on page 11
of the amended conditional approval it's
an unclear Authority legislative intent
comment because the board is imposing an
administrative fine if the line does not
submit documentation of continuing
education within the deadline set by the
board when they're being
audited the board has set a $50 fee if
they are 30 days past their deadline and
a $100 fee if they are more than 30 days
but less than 60 days past their
deadline in the appendix the board cites
this Authority as RSA
31012 1e which does Grant the board the
authority to assess administrative fines
for professional misconduct
however there is a question of whether
or not this particular conduct would
fall within the legislative meaning of
professional misconduct um there was
nothing found within the other statutes
that Define what professional misconduct
would
be so there was a little bit of a
question of whether or not the board
actually had the authority to set these
fines uh the board does say that they
have the authority because they are able
to establish rules establishing
administrative fines and the allocation
of disciplinary sanctions um of
misconduct by lenses and certified
individuals and they also argue that
within this particular proposal
specifically um phy
45.0 K they Define misconduct as a
violation of any provision of R 329 328
F RSA 328a and any rule adopted by the
board or any state or federal law
however ever defining misconduct within
the rules still does not address the
issue of whether or not it's statutorily
allowed so I just wanted the committee
to be aware if they had any questions on
that I have a question what's the
penalty if they never submit this
information Tina Kelly office of
professional liur and
certification um the penalty would be
under
c c which is if they do not sub they go
straight to a
hearing and or if the they report that
the amount of continued education they
received is less than required the same
thing the same thing yes and the board's
the board's um the way the board looked
at doing it this way was that this gives
the um leny the opportunity to decide I
want to pay the fine without having to
go through the um time and I'm sure
expense from missing work of having a
hearing as opposed to and if they
say I didn't get a notice and I don't
think this is fair or they say I was
sick then they can request a hearing and
they you know that would go before the
board so it gives the leny more
flexibility as to whether or not they
want to go before the board and it
limits the number of hearings the board
would have to have if every single
person went to a hearing
so that implies that that a substantial
number of physical therapists either
don't get their uh uh continuing
education or don't respond
promptly
it and I can speak I can only speak from
what I had seen and it wasn't a
lot 10 to 15 during a licensing period
but enough
to um
create a lot of um a lot of work to
track these people
down yes representing and then Senator
so um oplc now is having a has is
implementing a new online system
correct that is my understanding yes so
all of these issues
will be addressed because the licensing
renewals and Licensing is going to come
under that system eventually correct
they will go through that system to
submit continuing education yes okay so
that's my so I think that's an important
fact for everyone to know and then
number two I'm going to go back to these
rules that need to be cleaned up a
little bit because on page eight it
refers to
the board receiving the documents for
licensed renewals when in fact it's oplc
and throughout that whole page it says
board rather than
oplc
so I don't know if we have to adopt
these today but I'd like to put this
under the same umbrella as the board of
Podiatry and U postpone it until next
month to give you a chance to look into
this online system and um also um the
cleaning up of the of the
rules do we need to vote on that it
doesn't um it's within our deadline uh
correct a waiver would not be needed if
this is going to be
postponed okay so you're you you're
moving making a mo I'm moving a motion
to postpone with the with the hopes that
all this will be cleaned up by next
month and we can approve it then second
okay those in favor I iOS
osed yes please Senator um excuse me I
should have pulled on you that's okay um
I just want to I'm trying to understand
this SP to document the process there so
you have a fine if they don't file
within 30 days so is that the first fine
notice that goes out to them and then
you have another fine that if they don't
file within 30 to one to 60 there's a
second fine notice that goes out and
then if they don't do any of that then
they're automatically scheduled for a
hearing to um as to why they didn't
submit documentation is that the process
that would be the process but it's not
compounded fine so the fine would be $50
for the for and then $100 not $150 after
the just to clear up
that okay sen uh I also want to ask the
department to seek the legislative uh
solution to the comment on page 11 to
make sure that the Authority for the is
H
clear
okay any other discussion okay we'
already voted to postpone it
so have a lovely
month all
right that's the last of these all right
uh fines relative to hazardous waste
management Madam chair I'm going to pick
this up Kim um as you're aware this was
postponed
uh after lengthy discussion about this
at the last meeting uh there was
considerable concern about the uh um
expired rules for hazardous waste fines
um ultimately committee um had a concern
because of the fact that the department
indicated that the
proposed not the proposed fines but the
uh specified fines in the rules were
subject change by hearing officer um in
response to that the department has gone
in and for every fine they have changed
it to proposed so it's a proposed fine
and in addition to that they have given
us a draft initial proposal in which
they amend another rule to specify the
criteria by which uh they would
determine whether the fine needed to be
adjusted from the proposed
amount
okay Pam Monroe for the Department of
Environmental Services attorney moral
has correctly represented uh what we've
done here the actual procedural rules
that he referenced we filed the uh
request for fiscal impact statement last
evening so those rules will be um moving
forward and I've met with him to discuss
our
approach okay represent Bara
so the words proposed rules seem
nebulous to me what does that mean a
proposed rule I mean proposed fine I'm
sorry prop it is the starting point for
their
negotiations and I'm concerned about it
because hazardous waste management is
I'm sure there are people and
organizations of all sizes who are
dealing with this and I'm concerned that
you would get your naive or firsttime
user getting in charge okay you violated
the rules here's your here's your $3,000
a day fine for 10 days and just you know
say oh God I'm stuck and pay it whereas
a more experienced person would know
that's just the starting
point and so it's
easily uh subject
to what we call informal Ru making and
you know some people get a better deal
than
others well so the proposed F would be
in a notice and we would have a hearing
and there would be a decision rendered
that the hearing is is mandatory you
don't just let somebody mail in a check
and avoid the
hassle if they were going to go through
the adjudicative process correct there
could be U settlement agreements that
take place Madam chair repres BR what if
we were to say that rather than proposed
fines we have up to ,000 or up to
whatever the fine is because proposed is
rather I I just think I think that's
just too
uh that's just doesn't mean anything to
me if I were to get
that I would say something more
something more people are accustomed is
the word up to up to $1,500 or up to
3,000 I mean how does that sit with you
well the statute does provide the
department with authority up to $2,000
per violation and the statute requires
that we adopt rules to establish a
schedule of administrative fines that's
what these are and so there's been an
evaluation from the Department staff as
to the appropriate level of fine uh to
propose director Boral um
in response to representative groda it
just to clarify it's not that the fine
itself is proposed which would mean well
are you going to do a fine or not it's a
specific amount that is proposed and
then there is a variation on that
depending on the circumstances that
would be in uh the draft initial
proposal which by the way is a part of
the conditional approval request meeting
packet it's at the end of it if you wish
to look at it
yeses lying so again yeah I'm looking at
that last page of the conditional
approval page 12 and it does have like a
range so it explains like what the
default is giving given just a charge of
a uh of a minor potential for harm as
well as a minor deviation it says the
default 250 but then there's a range of
100 to 500 so the more you know the the
nuanced piece of that can be adjusted
and dealt with and that's true for all
of these and I'm assuming there' have to
be a determination in the adjudicated
process what is a that this is a minor
deviation and has minor potential for
harm and therefore it's a
$250 um default fine and adjusted from
there but I guess they did put structure
around it um and they do Define above um
what a major deviation of the
requirement is what a um moderate
potential for harm is they do
definitions in there as well so I think
it's they they put sides you know you on
on the road for that they can't cross
over on either side but left it so it
can be adjusted based on each individual
case director uh regarding the language
that representative grotus suggested um
it's staff's interpretation of the
statute that in one place it says up to
$2,000 so that would be the maximum but
then the statute also specifically
requires that the agency adopt a
schedule of fund
we would interpret that as to mean they
need to put fairly specific
amounts and uh also saying up to $2,000
I know we've made comments in the past
uh committee hasn't always made a
objection on it but if you simply say up
to $2,000 then what's the criteria
between a $100 fine and a $2,000 fine
okay where it appears that they have
looking at the table they've got from a
default fine of 250 for a minor
potential minor deviation up to $2,000
if it's a major deviation and major
potential for harm which strikes me as
re as that's fine I withdraw my concern
okay Senator uh just a comment I I saw
this as a way for the Department to give
an indication of what they thought the
severity was by either picking the
default or picking a higher or lower
number so I'm perfectly comfortable with
it and I will move the
item okay
second any further discussion or
comments yes represent hacken Phillips
uh does the um agency believe that the
$2,000 threshold is an appropriate
amount to
appropriately uh you know thwart these
types of um
um I guess potential for harm yeah I'm
just thinking you know $2,000 on the
grand scheme of things in my mind just
um I'm wondering you know if that is
really an appropriate amount should we
be considering for future legislation
maybe a higher threshold to thwart some
of these like you know possible
hazardous um environmental damage thank
you for the question I I am aware that
there are other statutes that have been
changed I think fairly recently to 4,000
I I don't know the answer to your
question that' be really a policy matter
that I think the uh Department would
reach out to the legislature if if we
didn't feel that we had that Authority I
think we um we would absolutely reach
out and seek that thank
you okay um as I re as I remember from
last month these rules have
been uh expired for 15 years or so that
is
correct and I did you find out when you
got that information from the attorney
general that was okay to work without
rules I believe it was early on in the
process but it you know wasn't in
writing
um and as I said we we stopped that this
commissioner issued in order stopping
that practice what we're here today is
to is to correct where we are and I
think as I represented the last time
this is one of the programs there are
others that we're working on that will
be coming before you which is why we
felt it appropriate to adjust our
procedural rules to address the concerns
of the
committee
okay yes Senator so again representative
hacken Phillips point just remember some
of these fines aren't are per incident
fine so you may have five incidents that
are rolled up and it'll be a $10,000
fine because each incident subject up to
$22,000 so it's a cumulative fine not
per incident not necessarily a holistic
whole F
Well I'm particularly concerned that
with a program that was operating under
verbal instructions from the attorney
general that they didn't need a rule
when the law was changed to say expire
rules cannot be
enforced they didn't even bother to get
that opinion in writing so I understand
you have a new commissioner but I think
you ought to take that back to the
people that were there
working obliviously to the law for years
I share your concern I could tell you
know the department has 133 chapters of
administrative rules I believe I've
counted them before and
um I can represent to you I I've been in
this job for three years and is a
priority of the department not to let
any of their rules expire this is one of
133 and we are here to correct the
issues going forward but I I hear your
concern I've represented that to the
commissioner and the department is well
aware that's a con concern of this
committee
okay all right do we have any motion Jim
already moved it ice second it has been
moved all right any further
discussion those in favor I
opposed all right good
luck all right fish and
game um this is uh 2023 187 sporting
club youth feasant events um Kim
indicated that she has no comments on
the proposal the only reason it's before
the committee is that these rules
expired in May of this year um the rules
are for annual pheasant hunting events
uh for Youth and generally generally
these occur in the fall so it may be
that they've not enforced the rule since
May but that would be a question for the
Department morning yeah good morning um
Berg I'm the chief of the wildlife
division um that is correct these
there's actually only been two of these
events uh since
2012 um there were there were two
different dates of expiration in the
rules um and it was it was a mistake by
us that we missed we missed the second
um you'll notice that section H um was
up to date and the rest had expired um
there has not been an event since these
rules expired in May
so figured that but director moral I
would note that there is a conditional
approval request for this thank you move
to conditionally approved
second any
discussion seeing none those in favor I
opposed all right thank you very much
and good luck thank you
okay uh so the board of education has an
interim rule
2023 D6
um and they have requested that this be
postponed so that they can work on a
conditional approval request the jail C
deadline is until January 3rd so if the
committee chooses to postpone there's no
issue there okay do we have a motion so
moved discussion those in favor I I
opposed okay thank you very that was
easy all right do we have any
information on the objection responses
yet
uh yes I
believe um yes for the first one 2020
3116 uh from Board of Engineers I
believe the agency is going to ask for a
revised preliminary objection to address
comments so moved um although I I think
we should hear from the agency about
that okay this is just my understanding
from Kim's note so
good morning Tina Kelly office of
professional LIC Insurance
certification and I believe this is one
of Kim's right I I was speaking with Kim
regarding this and there are a few more
things that needed to be that we need to
work on so that's why we're requesting
the
revised um preliminary objection
response or
objection they really want to postpone
Madam chair well do you need an object a
revised objection or could we just
postpone dealing with it we
need they would need the revised
objection to make the
changes so moved second okay could I
have a represent the same issues with
these rules concerning the board and
Licensing also so let's make sure we get
that too thanks all right Madam chair
yes uh the second on
that was it Senator gray or yourself
we'll give it to Senator
gray any any further
discussion all right those in favor I I
opposed thank
you Department of Agriculture that they
come
back the second objection response 2023
135 from uh Department of Agriculture
markets and food um the committee had
voted to uh preliminarily object based
on staff
comments the rule itself contains uh one
section in AGR
700 uh it that section by itself uh
really doesn't work it needs the other
rules around it which are also expired
um the department has uh already already
initiated U or is planning to do regular
rul making uh very shortly to put in the
other
rules
morning hit the button buttons on the on
the
base there we go
newbie Patricia Benner for the
Department of Agriculture
um again in in our response we apologize
to committee for not being represented
on um August 17th um new to the position
and there was a miscommunication that
the commissioner would be here in my
stad um so we have corrected some of the
concerns and um have initiated uh the
full chapter um it's actually supposed
to be in the register today so uh we
have a public hearing on November 15th
for the full set of rules
okay any questions from the
committee so I I just Madam chair excuse
me represent hacken Phils has a question
or comment so I just want to make sure
I'm understanding this correctly that
the rule 700 section really does need
the complement of the remaining
surrounding section to make sense that
is correct but today we're just um
talking about the 700 section just one
particular section within 700 okay thank
you I have a question about so once
we once we get to the approval of these
rules does that mean that the Department
of Agriculture is all up to date with
their
rules uh no the department has a number
of chapters that are expired
um but I think as far as the 700s U that
should take care of
this so I guess my comment and I guess
it's to the
committee not to ol at all and then and
the agencies is that we hear about these
expired rules and when they're a year or
two you can understand that but this is
2008 and previously it was 2009
so how is it that this happens I I
just there's there yes please um the
department has never had to my knowledge
any person to do their rulem uh Patricia
was hired specifically to do that uh
earlier this year and hopefully they are
going to be moving forward with all
their expired
rules
perfect thank you glad to hear
that right so Madam chair I guess my
question is we can we can still approve
705 this rule knowing that they're
coming forward correct yes I move to
approve second okay second by Senator
gray any
discussion those in favor I
opposed all right thank you very much
and good luck with all your
rules uh with regard to the Department
of Health and Human Services the fost
family care licensing requirements the
department did file their revised
objection response I have had an
opportunity to look at it based on the
reasons for the revised objection I did
not have any additional comments and I
do believe the changes address them uh
just to remind the committee the issues
that needed to be addressed on the
revised objection response were that the
department had to make clear that the
mandator immunizations were for adult
caregivers as it just said all household
caregivers so they did make that change
and
additionally they also changed the
requirement um or the recommendations
from those number of agencies from just
saying the immunizations to specifying
that's the number of immunization doses
dosage route of administration spacing
in a age to make it clear that they're
not going on the recommendations of
which immunizations need to be required
just how the ones that are required
under the state statutes need to be
administered so I would say that this
does address that and then additionally
they threw in an additional paragraph
saying that no additional immunization
shall be required for children who are
household members of a foster care home
other than immunizations that are
required for other schoolage children in
the state so I would I have no further
comment Ms on this
one
okay good morning Allison radme
administrator for the administrative
rules unit of the Health and Human
Services um thank you attorney reikard I
actually have nothing to add and we'll
take questions if needed okay any
questions represent
L um no I don't have any questions they
answered they they fixed all the
problems in there and I'm very
appreciated of that okay anyone
else approve second okay we're moving to
to approve their revised uh objection
response any comments or
questions those in favor I opposed and
I'm sorry madam chair who was the second
on that
[Music]
vote I had Senator gray is the initial
and then and I seconded that
representative representative Le all
right thank
you all
right we do have an item for other
business uh this morning you will see in
addition to the agenda at your stations
there's also a package with a number of
forms that have been revised by OS these
forms have been revised due to the
updates to 541a and also
91a um and I could very briefly go over
the changes um the first one which is
the ru making notice form the only two
changes were that we are asking agencies
to include whether a rule Implement
implements a state statute for the first
time that is just something that we've
done on our own based on conversations
that we've been having um with uh other
members of the uh committee as well as
other staff um for the House of
Representatives um just to make it
easier for people to know whether a rule
is either implementing a statute for the
first time or as we're
seeing needed to be implemented before
but is now just starting to be
implemented the other change to this
form is that we've included information
for the agency to put on whether or not
a hearing will also be available
electronically that is in response to a
change to 91a which does allow agencies
to have electronic hearings or hybrid
hearings however that um change I don't
believe applies to boards and
commissions just
yet the next form is the Contin uation
of ruem hearing once again just
including information should an agency
want to do a hearing electronically or a
hybrid
hearing um the extension of public
comment deadline also the same change
due to 91a for the electronic
hearings um change in electronic access
for virtual hearing or hybrid rulemaking
hearing this one is um new in response
to 91a to to allow the agency to publish
more information for the public so that
they can attend a hearing electronically
should they wish
and next would be the cover sheet for
the final proposal this one has a number
of new changes due to the uh updates in
541a the first is the requirement that
an agency has
to in addition to the final proposal
also submit a report or summary of the
public comments received on the initial
proposal and explain how those were
addressed on the final proposal so just
like an incorporation by reference
statement that's something that they
have to file with the final proposal
additionally we are now requiring that
forms be filed as well with the final
proposal um that was also an update to
the
statute there is also a new process with
regard to fiscal impact statements the
statute was amended to allow an agency
to request an amend fiscal impact
statement um and so that has also been
included on this form whether or not the
agency has asked and received an amended
fiscal impact
statement and the final form is the
expedited repeal notice form once again
just including a line for electronic
access if the agency is going to do that
due to
91a any questions from the committee
director moral uh these forms would be
used for initial proposals filed on or
after October 3D they would not to apply
to anything that was in the process
prior to
that thank you for not not having uh
virual actor
requirements okay so these if the
committee has no objections these are
going to go into effect as of the date
of the Law changes correct yes okay
all right there probably should be a
vote to accept these move to
accept Okay Senator line beat Senator
gray for the motion but I'll come
Senator gray is seconding it any further
discussion those in favor I
post all right thank you we also have a
letter from the home builders that we
probably need to talk about Mr Mayberry
are you going to talk to us about
it do we have a copy of the letter ah is
that the copy of the letter right
there
uh good question I got it
electronically I don't think you got
everybody else did all
right
okay I will forward it to um anybody who
didn't get it
um who who didn't get
it all right I WR it
land can you email it to the entire
committee I I'd have to do it one by one
and that's a I'm not certain all right
then I'll keep going it's going to your
legis they emails guys so back and
Phillips are you doing that let Matt
tell them at the meeting about what we
thought yes I'll I'll I'll do that there
so Matt if you wanna um Mr mayber if you
want to tell us the contents of the
email and why you're here before the jel
thank you Senator thank you madam chair
my name is Matt Mayberry I'm the
Executive Vice President of the New
Hampshire Home Builders
Association um I apologize to the Comm
members I I asked someone to send it the
letter out to everyone and I don't know
what happened so I
apologize um we wrote to everyone
yesterday asking for a potential revisit
of a vote that you folks took on a rule
that
was EnV
dwq 1500 the alteration of
terrain it was a rule that was uh
requested by the uh New Hampshire Dees
that would changed some of the language
in the alteration of terrain uh
permitting for building
homes it was presented to the committee
as it had no Financial impact to the
state a state agency or any privately
held business that it was bureaucratic
in nature when I spoke to New Hampshire
Dees for an explanation they said this
is just
housekeeping no need to worry about
it come to find out after was passed it
has a huge impact on the building the
Residential Building Community here in
New Hampshire there is a project in
Grafton County that is experiencing an
additional
$250,000 increase in cost because of
that rule imple
implementation in straford County there
is a housing project of 76 units and
that has a $100,000
cost every penny count in
this right now the interest rate this
morning is
8.42% so every $10,000 that gets
transferred to the
consumer to your
constituents they'll be paying almost
$228,000 by the end of that
mortgage it counts if we had known from
when I contacted New Hampshire Dees I
asked if there was an executive summary
of the rule is it because I was given a
short window between notification and
the public hearing I asked if there was
an executive summary available no there
was not I asked what happened if a if a
representative or a senator asked for an
executive
summary I was told we'll answer their
specific
question but don't worry about it it's
bureaucratic in nature there's no impact
to builders no impact to agencies this
is housekeeping
not even
close and so we're asking Jal car to
please consider revisiting that Vote or
staying that rule
or give us time to work with Dees on
this so we fully understand the impact
that's only two
Builders that's
$350,000 on two projects when we need
every stick of housing we can get so
we're asking you please consider your
vote please allow us time to work with
Dees and come back to you with a revised
rule that works for everyone guess them
what they want and helps us keep
building houses
please director moral um Mr Mayberry
could you indicate what particular rule
or rules
uh have this problem and what
specifically the problem is or how it
increases the cost absolutely Madam
chair I have to go to fiscal but just
for the Committees it was on the August
17th agenda it was item number 2023
136 which should help you uh look it up
if you need to and I apologize for
having to go to Fisco that's that's fine
the as I recall that was on consent and
I was astonished that that kind of a
rule was on consent with no
comments but there weren't
any
when when anyone tells me it's
bureaucratic in nature you can relax I'm
going to relax um so sir um what we're
doing now is Santa gray requested that
information we're working with the
engineers who are much smarter than I am
on what word or words triggered
these changes so we're trying to get
that that request came in last night I
sent it to the engineers that involved
in at least of the two project
referenced here so we're working on that
data for you
sir okay any mam yes so my understanding
is I don't know that we can necessarily
go back and revisit and revote a ruled
especially from a month and a half ago
um however what we could do is petition
the agency my understanding is they have
not implemented the rule yet um and if
they even if they have we can ask them
to either Implement an emergency rule
due to the fiscal impact of the citizens
in the Hampshire they'd be allowed to do
an emergency rule to address this
housing being the critical nature that
it is um and the cost of housing being a
critical nature of it is I I I'd rather
not have a rule that's creating
significant impact to our developers and
trying to implement housing in the state
of New Hampshire so my motion would be
to petition the agency to stay the rule
and if they've already implemented the
rule to bring forth an emergency rule
that may assist um and work with the
home builders to get craft that
emergency
rule mam chair yes uh Pam excuse me Pam
Monroe from the dep department is here
if you wouldd like to ask the department
any questions okay thank you Senator
chandley I'll withdraw my motion till we
here thank you madam chair and and that
is partly what concerns me is I am not
prepared to act on this in any way even
staying a rule um at this point I just
feel I this is the very first um I've
heard about it I haven't seen any letter
I did check my email I'm I'm sorry
you're not in my email list so I'm
having a little more difficulty that's I
am not I'm just saying the nature is
that this is really an Abrupt change and
that I I think that you know to act on
something in such haste could be
dangerous and set a very bad precedent
um I'm totally sympathetic and I I
respect what um Senator Lang said about
um we we need every stick of housing um
however let's do this thoughtfully and
appropriately thank you I tend to get
represent BR I agree with what Senator
Chanley said and furthermore I'd like to
know what the house bill was that
prompted this and what the intent of
that bill was because this is all you
just don't establish rules without
legislation correct so I'd like to
backtrack it that far it's if it was
started as housekeeping updates the the
alteration of terrain rules might have
just come up for review um before they
expired I don't remember specifically
any but there could be some
legislation uh I agree with Senate
Chanley myself I would strongly
recommend that as the home builders are
figuring out which which parts are bad
they formally write a letter to the
commissioner and request him to revise
the
rule that will give the agency 30 days
to come up with an
answer and will it it will at least put
them on notice that there are concerns
in a bill in a rule that they were
advertising as minor technical cleanup
yes ma'am but we have projects in the in
the pipeline right now that are being
delayed well we'll continue it too but
in any it it certainly will stake out
your position that you know you you were
misinformed director and I think Senator
Lang mentioned that uh and for the newer
committee members the committee cannot
to now uh make a change to a rule that's
already been adopted that can only be
done in the same committee meeting uh it
used to be that you could do that
subsequently but it ran into some
serious problems in doing that so the
committee in its own rules decided that
if you were going to make a change to a
rule that had been voted on it had to be
done at the same meeting okay so Senor l
so again my understanding again my my
motion for petition for them to seek
possible emergency rule making was for
that reason was because they'd have to
go through all new rule Mak proc process
hearings and everything else I guess to
adapt change the rule again which will
delay six months I think is our process
for public hearings and everything else
by a petition to ask them to visit in
possible emergency rules doesn't mean
they have to do that it just is saying
that we want you to look at this because
that is an impact on the Hampshire
housing that was an unintended
consequence they doesn't force them to
do an emergency rule it just says that
we identified an issue that has
significant potential cost effect to our
citizens which is one of the conditions
of an emergency rule is is um financial
and it would allow them they can say no
we looked at it we don't want to do an
emergency Rule and that's fine but it
just says that the this board would like
them to at least review it and look at
it and and it makes them respond in a
timely fashion and not just ignore a
Citizens requests I think that we should
put that on the agenda for the next
meeting so that we are able to in the
meantime look at whatever the initial
letter from the home builders and
whatever whatever other date
they have to show us and also reread the
rule may may I just ask can I just ask a
question Mr maybery the thing I'm I want
to make sure I'm understanding
is are are you saying that the that the
department of of Environmental Services
has has said in these cases you point
out has said
listen um we this would have this what
you're doing would have been fine under
the old rule uh but now the rule has
been changed and it's now because of
this change that we're saying we're
taking a different position than we took
before or that's what they're saying so
their position is not what you were
doing before would have been a problem
anyway uh but this now it's now even a
clearer problem correct in the um in the
letter you'll see a a case from
Waterville Valley in which the developer
went to the state and said are we the
beta test on this you know how are we
working these um they had been they
submitted an
application was approved and through
that approval
process this rule was introduced and
everything
changed and so they had to re-engineer
re environmental study and come up with
new Retention Ponds that caused a
$250,000 increase because of that rule
so you're correct sir has that rule gone
into effect yes ma'am
and it applied to a pro a project in
process yes ma'am two
projects and I've submitted to my 500
members please send us if this rule is
affecting you please come through
because santra I completely agree this
is on a short schedule for
everyone that we're asking all of our
members send us your testimony if this
is impacting you please come through and
these first two jump in right away
saying it's hitting Us in the between
the eyes it's in effect right now that's
why we're asking for a
stay yeah I mean you know the other I
guess I I I completely agree with the
senator on on this I mean and I think
what we're what we're doing because the
problem I have is this I you may be
completely right but you know I I guess
I'd like to see the language I don't
know what the language of the old rule
was or the language of the new rule was
and what exactly the change is and so so
without you know you may be completely
right but I think before we take any
action we ought to have you know we
ought to know the whole story so to
speak that's and my concern is that I
think we don't right now absolutely
completely
agree yes representative
grassy yeah I would have to agree of of
holding on to this because one of the
concerns I have in this is that it's
talking it seems to be it's talking
about bio retention uh ponds and their
construction and uh this is something I
have a a little bit of expertise in and
the concern that I have about this is if
I I want to know how this is going to
affect communities because we have storm
water management requirements and
communities now the federal government
has passed down that are very costly to
a lot of local communities and this may
be something that would just
transferring a cost from one side to
another side that you know that a
developer may be able to reduce cost but
then the taxpayers are going to have to
pick it up on the other side that's the
only concern I would have that we take
our time before we move move ahead with
this to take a look at how it affects
both sides of that equation okay Senator
and finally I just want to make sure I
understand it's I I you uh I don't think
you moved it but you suggest we put this
on the next agenda um would that be in
two weeks or would
we you would it be a continued meeting
or direct we haven't there's a continued
meeting that is scheduled that we have
not yet cancelled uh director do we have
anything else that would be appropriate
for that uh no I I think the items we've
postponed have all been to the next
regular
meeting okay so it would probably be in
a
month correct okay unless unless someone
moves to make having a continued meeting
simply to address that
issue all right anyone
else okay director I would note that um
with Senator Lang's motion or idea to
have the agency respond I think it's
going to be very difficult for them
unless they know the rules that uh are
creating this
problem I would do
that okay so the more information you
can get us and the sooner the better
um any other questions for Mr
Mayberry yes ma'am and and we'll also uh
petition the uh Commissioner of Dees
thank you and I'll include that letter
for all of you and thank you for your
time and your consideration I know you
have a lot on your agenda but thank you
and if the agency what is here I'd like
to find out what their side of this is
because it uh it's rather
shocking you on the meeting
sorry my Pam nice to meet you nice to
meet you legal administrator at
Dees uh Madam chair I I this is news to
me um I don't know if this letter uh who
who was the letter directed to at the
department sir uh to members of J dep
okay so the department has not received
a letter um not aware of what the issue
is um we stayed here because attorney
moral uh you know relayed the
concern uh so okay we will act on it as
soon as we see it um we undertook um as
we always do we reached out to our
stakeholders for this rul making uh this
comes as a surprise to
me okay and you will of course forward
that letter at any more details to the
appropriate person at
De okay you can direct them to me sir
and my associate Courtney Lockwood is
attorney for lamb Resources management
program so we will address these thank
you thank you all right any further
discussion on
this all right seeing none we have uh
agreed not to have the continued meeting
and therefore we will be uh meeting
again on
November 20th 18th 18th I think it
is I think it's the 16th 16th okay thank
you that glad I
asked okay we will be we will meet then
this will be an item on the agenda so
we'll be glad to hear from both of you
we are
aour